does Amazon's announcement that they are
rebranding epics to MGM plus suddenly
make a lot of the rumors we've been
hearing about Stargate make a little bit
more sense indeed it does
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so a couple of days ago Amazon and MGM
announced they are rebranding their epic
streaming service and they are now
calling it MGM Plus
that's original
Disney plus Paramount plus MGM plus okay
I see where they're going here
shouldn't there have been a memo or
something but that got me thinking this
announcement didn't really make sense to
me initially but does it actually
suddenly put a lot of the Stargate
rumors into a slightly different light
and make them make a little bit more
sense well the more I think about it the
more I think it does so first of all
like my instinct on this one was why are
Amazon doing this we assumed they were
just going to absorb everything from MGM
into Amazon Prime that is at the end of
the day their premium streaming service
but maybe that was never actually the
plan maybe the plan was to take epics
and turn that into a competitive
streaming service on its own we want to
take that chance Harry you want to roll
those dice
now all of a sudden
we can ignore what they're doing with
Amazon Prime because we need to start
looking at Epix instead
now MGM have already announced four new
shows and none of them are Stargate now
I actually read the story on gateworld
about this and you know the
disappointment they're not even Stargate
and the confusion but if you are a
regular side tracker you should already
kind of know why they've not announced
Stargate because they're not ready they
don't quite know what to do with
Stargate they're not even 100 certain
they want to push forwards with it
but
a rumor I heard about six months ago
that I told you on this channel at the
time was that I heard Amazon never
intended to put Stargate at least
initially on Amazon Prime that they had
an idea to put it somewhere else now
then a room came around and I think
mostly on gate world that maybe they
were going to put it on freevy a channel
on Amazon Prime where they put a lot of
new content and they are commissioning
new things for that channel where they
have um adverts on there so um it
actually is a free to view Channel now
that made no sense to me really this is
going to be a big very expensive project
in Stargate we're looking at 10 million
dollars an episode at least 100 million
dollars minimum for the first season now
that's going to be a big investment I
couldn't see them putting something so
prestigious and something that will have
so much interest on freevy but what I
could see is them putting it on the new
Epix or MGM plus Channel
now you've got to remember MGM doesn't
just own MGM intellectual properties it
owns uh United Artists it also owns
Orion pictures so Epix actually does
have an awful lot of not just MGM but
products from those as well they also
have lots of deals through epics for
um smaller production companies smaller
Studios all of these things that Amazon
then bought Apex compared to even Amazon
Prime HBO Max Etc it's quite a small
Channel at the moment but ahead of that
channel Steven Wright has already made
comments about how excited he is and how
much investment Amazon are willing to
put into this project now I would argue
they wouldn't be bothering with this
rebranding if they weren't really
planning on trying to make Epix MGM plus
a really big competitive streaming
service in its own right
and it would also explain why Amazon
Prime aren't really pushing and aren't
desperate to get all the MGM back
products including Stargate on Amazon
Prime as quickly as possible something
that we all expected them to do almost
immediately
because they never intended it to go on
Amazon Prime in the first place they
were hoping to get it onto MGM plus oh
by the way if you do like the content
please consider hitting the join button
and becoming a fully fledged side
tracker you can also go to
side-track.com and pick marvelous
merchandise all of these little things
really help the channel also if you're
new to the channel like subscribe hit
that Bell notification and share the
video wherever the hell you want now the
room I heard six months ago suddenly
makes sense they never intended for it
to go on Amazon Prime or freebie they
were waiting for it to go on to MGM Plus
so why haven't they announced it well
like I say if you're a regular site
tracker you know they're not ready
another reason though is that Epix isn't
moving over to MGM plus actually until
January 15 2023 so I am certain between
now and then we'll get little
announcements from lots of different
shows that they plan to put onto MGM
plus but I don't think we'll get any
really big announcements until either we
get a little bit closer to the time or
actually around the launch date of MGM
plus they're going to want to maximize
clicks on social media
so all of a sudden another rumor that I
heard makes maybe a little bit more
sense that we probably wouldn't hear
anything about Stargate until the turn
of the year I was told even two or three
months ago that was going to be at least
six months and then I was told again
when we heard these rumors about new
showrunners Etc that we would hear
something by around Christmas
then we get this announcement that Epix
is switching over to MGM plus just after
Christmas coincidence well we're gonna
have to wait and see and this is purely
speculation this is me two plus two
equals four a little bit it might be a
little bit two plus two equals six here
but hey we've only got a couple of
months until we're gonna find out so
fingers crossed hashtag we want Stargate
let's hope that this is one more step
towards that big announcement that we're
all desperately waiting to hear that
Stargate new series has been greenlit if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification
really helps us out also if you enjoy
the content consider hitting that join
button because that really supports the
channel as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time
[Music]